hey how's it going how are you how are
you doing because last time we talked to
you is during the golden globes it was
in the middle of night you were in
london you were and now you're here yeah
i was in a hotel and now i also in the
hotel but in la and without my entire
class which is so strange they're all in
london right now we're actually with
them tonight exclusively the rest of the
entire cat do you have anything you want
to say to them i know because you're
kind of walking lonely i like them i
think they're all quite good at no i'm
joking they're amazing and i miss them
all and um i wish i was with you guys oh
i love that what was that experience
like playing charles the lovable charles
at first and then it turned into the
charles we may not like so much so much
yeah uh it was great i've had the time
in my life making it it was like
two of the most special years
and uh yeah it's sad not to be together
to celebrate the end of it but um we'll
celebrate back in london soon yeah now i
do have a question about that what do
you do to like put charles to bed
because you he's been a part of your
life for a long time what do you do to
like make that chapter go away
i don't know i thought it would happen
quite easily because there was a whole
global
pandemic that's sort of that
charles i i feel like it was just kind
of
it look it was
it was a long time playing him i loved
it and my back was like aching after
because i was arched over all the time
oh yeah and so it was just a lot of um
acupuncture that got me out guys that's
right cause you did that neck thing a
lot you did it really well um dominic
west takes over did you talk to dominic
or did you give him any tips or have you
had any a chance to catch up i i
honestly as soon as i heard it was
dominant i was like dominic needs no
tips from me dominic is like the
greatest of the greats so
no he hasn't called i'm waiting i'm
still waiting by my phone what did you
think when you heard during the oprah
interview that megan and harry watched
i actually didn't know that oh they said
that they said they dipped in and out
they did watch so what do you think
about that i mean that's great i love
that i'm quite pleased i mean any
audience for the crown is great i think
it's i i'm so glad they watch it and i'm
you know i think it's just uh it's one
of those shows that has touched a lot of
people so
i think we believe that the royals
really are secretly sitting in
buckingham palace big fans they are all
on netflix
i'm sure that i'm sure what would you
say to charles if you could say one
thing to him
uh i've been asked this before and i
never have a good answer and it's
ridiculous that i'm coming to the end of
the road with talking about the crown
and i still have no good answer but the
answer i have given before is i just
want to ask him if he has a boiled egg
with every meal which apparently he does
yeah which i feel like is a good
question so that would be my first
question do you have a plus one here
tonight who's your date uh my date is
actually my agent who i love so much and
he's like coming coming along the line
he's somewhere out there and he's a
dream so how do you pick because you
because this you know we're in a new
normal so they say you can only bring
one person how do you say okay it's the
agent
honestly i didn't know that so i
might
i love my agent here my girlfriend's in
new york and i would have loved her to
be here so that was my my bad but um it
would have been my girlfriend how much
are you gonna party tonight without your
lady
not i honestly good answer he's going in
he's going in
he's going in